it's the blind leading the blind so here
we go Doctor Who series 10 episode 5
don't mind the nails it's been a odd
kind of weekend oxygen reminder I don't
do spoiler-free anymore so rolling right
into it I think this is the best episode
of this series so far I really really
enjoyed this one I hesitate to say that
it's a flat-out great episode it's
definitely very good I need well really
what I need to do is I need to re-watch
the thing before I can really make that
call
I'm gonna to do that soon but I
basically I had technical issues I miss
chunks of it the sound cut out at me at
one point but yet despite all of that I
really really liked it so I think that
says a bit about it so you know God what
is there to say about this ok here's the
main thing despite the fact that on a
logic level I knew repeatedly throughout
the episode that bill wasn't dead
despite to fake outz on that and that
the doctor and the rest that seemed
wasn't going to die the tension was
still there I still felt you know my
adrenaline go up I still felt the nerves
I still had the aah and that you'll
really shows how well executed this is I
mean I I wish I could think of a better
comparison but it's like when you see
Titanic and my favorite scene in that
movie is when they crash into and they
and they scrape up against the iceberg
and how tense that music is and you
watch all these people on this crew
scrambling and panicking and you know
what's going to happen but you're still
crossing your fingers going oh come on
please it was like that only in Reverse
whereas in that case I knew they weren't
going to make it this one I knew they
were but I'm still like oh come on and
that that always comes down to execution
the tension in this execution is
incredibly well handled the setting is
very cool and it um it turned around a
couple of points where I just I thought
like
when we first saw those suits walk
around when the like my immediate
thought was uh zombies and have I
mentioned that I'm really over zombies
at this point ah they're not zombies
this is the suit walking around with a
dead body which is a nicely creepy image
and a nicely creepy thought I'm coming
back to bill and those kinds of the to
think out that she had that when she was
passing out because she couldn't breathe
that all man that was terrifying they
really sort of put you that because
she's in a vacuum so the sound goes out
um yeah you know in that case time was
supposed to go out as opposed to you
know when they went dead I mean it
wasn't supposed to but that my problems
anyway so you know that goes out you see
you know the the effects on her face who
gave me you did this
ah it just looks really unpleasant and I
really love the doctor sort of little
mini speech about having a good death
that just that is like I mean Kapow he
does delivers these speeches so well
when he gets the chance to do them and I
like that I like that was at a
stand-your-ground moment I like that as
a yeah we're going to die but we're
going to die with purpose and they're
going to know that we were here and I
get I always I tend to enjoy that as a
sentiment from characters anyway is he
coming from the doctor loved it um the
whole idea I let again something that I
thought it was a dislike but they didn't
go where I thought
whereas I thought initially we were
dealing with zombies I also thought
initially oh you know there it looks
like they're dealing with an AI problem
but really it's going to turn out though
there's a saboteur on the station and
the bus and they didn't go there and I'm
it would have been so predictable and it
would have taken me out of thing if they
have but they didn't and now I suppose
you can still technically say a person
was behind it because they always a
corporate mandate but I like that it
just it's it's not about the one guy
who's offering yeah it's like it's this
bigger thing that they're dealing with
there's definitely
bit of a recurring thing going on with
this series because we you know we had a
similar sort of capitalistic things
going on in thin ice even the last
episode knock-knock it wasn't a
capitalism thing but it was sort of this
people as fuel thing it's it's you know
as fuel as a resource as just something
to be used up and consumed I think we
have our recurring theme of the series
and I'm I'll be curious to see how how
that either pays off is it going to
become blatant and made like part of the
the actual upfront text of the of the
series or is it going to be left as a
subtext some recurring theme don't know
but it's working for me so far I'm
diggin that I really liked having
nardole along with I like the dynamic
that nardole has with the doctor I like
that Naruto kept trying to trip him up I
like that he's there holding the fluid
links in the TARDIS can't go anywhere
without this doctor says yeah who told
you that well you did exactly just
throws the levers the TARDIS goes like
that love it
I don't like nardole as much when he's
panicky and screaming that doesn't work
for me as much so those moments are a
little iffy but you know when he's just
when he's just trying to get the doctor
back on the TARDIS and the the strength
he has does the character when he was
confronting the doctor at the end I was
impressed with I will reiterate I like
nardole I know some people don't I think
in some cases people just don't like
Matt Lucas which is fair there are
actors who I just don't like and it
doesn't matter what role they're playing
ricky gervais oh god um but so I get
that but for me he's really working bill
is still working and you know she still
she asked the the interest she asked the
questions I was asking like being the
instant that they established the
forcefield keeping the oxygen and I was
like well hang on why they need the
helmets when they were outside this has
been last that exact question hooray so
it by having her ask those questions
outright and ask them in a way that that
feels like it's coming rooted in her
character it makes a lot of things that
are expositional feel less
ditional because just the nature of the
dialogue in the kind of relationship she
has with the doctor allows us to all
flow and feel more organic and I like
all of that um the doctor still being
blind is an interesting wrinkle I'm not
I'm not entirely sure what I think about
that at this point I mean a lot of its
going to depend on what it's like next
episode and you know and to see how it
affects my initial thought is probably
not going to be a huge effect because he
seemed to function pretty well without a
sight in this episode and yet at the
same time I think to myself it's still
gonna kneecap him a bit and I'll be
interested to see how that plays out I I
will be curious to see you if they can
really strike the balance because I
think it's something they can either be
overplayed or underplayed I think
they're more risk of underplaying
showing how confident they've shown him
to be without his sight already so you
know we'll see in what ways it actually
hampers him but the doctor doesn't
usually carry over physical issues from
episode to episode mental scars
certainly he's got more than a share of
those but this this is new this is an
interesting wrinkle ow you know it's
hard to it's hard to say whether or not
it's a good idea based on this episode
alone I gotta I gotta see where it goes
it's the sort of thing on paper I go
don't think so but I since we've done it
we're here I will I will take a look at
at what they have next time and I think
that about sums just that it's just a
really strong episode um and again it's
it is execution because it's a fairly
standard you know enclosed space they're
finding survivors the setup is not
particularly original I did like the
fact that they were mostly combating the
AI even though it wasn't like an AI gone
mad story I like when they have to you
know go up against just computer
rationale sometimes they can go the
wrong way like with the hosts in voids
of the dams but it was one of the only
elements I liked in sleep no more you
know when the guy had to sing to the
door to get it to open because just how
the
forget a Iwerks I love that kind of
stuff so I love them to see them trying
to battle and work around and deal with
this thing that that is programmed to do
the survey and they just have to figure
out a way to out think it and around the
ways that it's going to react to what
they do and I always like those kinds of
stories so again this is just this is
just tightly executed is what this is
this is this is a spot-on delivery for
what it was trying to do so oxygen
I enjoyed it quite a bit what were your
thoughts on it whatever they were drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]